[Music]
hey juice and gb figure and this is the new
mini iphone and is
is a mini review oh [ __ ] also need a
backup and how long they me this
video would go that's in depth reviews
to it mit henk dissel feel like  a
pretty
mini review richard bos as long dead
grandy white black give you the iphone 12
that's the video forth link of ipod touch
check out the giant team at jardino
mostly don't have things so know about
this new generation of iphone 12
am a-ga  de iphone 12 mini en 12 promax
dropping so yes i'm dripping two
videos at the same time this would be a
button mini en als ik blowde video
button max should you be more interested
in venray
het is mini white people including new
york your excited  for i know the flagship
smartphone and compaq size
the week gamora more so interiors
mini iphone 12 is i the summit of and
well this is there is a people asking for
frank down that is of course in ferry i am
going to test in apples so many things  but
is from sc is  the sine yes of 12 cm
design things for sites are cameras
sim performance same software features
just small er for corsa china
smartphone
i was smaller barry and and or scabs
know groin injury money insights to do
the same things you in the big van zo my
job haze  reviewer for you is defined oh
it's action brass more stuff and
save debate arranges salami started the
battery juice business one day lieferbar
goal week project european skimming in
heavy and light for these views
so had so far iphone berryl
iphoneiphone 12 mini baby  shampoo bar
manageable
like happy days' you can chill and 100%
inserts devisscher our mcgregor
these audi and things pd gravel idea the
very person with frank for a large
screen on time which well this one is na
really very impressive well as already
summertime weiteres die  iphones and free
yourself you a better user and phones is
challenging for wel i will end up with
three days and battery life over de
quotes van mon  tague o ja fusing miss
jenny die p&o at freddy's were home
screen and gaming
navigation
journal of stuff you can fire brigade de
battery and kill a and d so this is true
as a kind of our find its not great but
it's not fair and why people studio gtx
sli of other people
considering and buying mini phones
hard lenses arguing the nfi is a tank
that anyway and de resigns here is
your get very compact phone and angelique
scanning campismo sometimes mens it
becomes silent house those like this'
beeksestraat de e14 bionic touching  the
future proof for years to come
kit kats him the best cameras in the
industry
excellent video code and since the nu
nash designer at chile other morskring
real estate den tribe die us beautiful
iphones i de iphone apps die which
still house the badger puzzles anne
forehead  and the chance to use the
iphone 12 mini next to the iphone sc nec
sms upgrade van four points even
een cel cda pipelife orange danny die po
life it's still really know  screen
narrower anne smartphone but okay how that was
the promise it's there briefing of the
iphone 12 josh narrower so narrow battery
li-po vita okay from the between engine tanks
tiny wings that your menari is of need of
care about but because i've  never find
you i am the reviewer other share my
anyway i service you so smartphone
or at least narrower speakers
the sexuality of size grill on each
of the iphone sizes with a mini
have morning crow and narrow is everywhere
speaker
macd the max volume and  sound for the
article i notice to the words and so
there is any dared mini speaker
ben smartphone least morris service area
on the back for accessories and actually
the section dollar ladder macs-lift what
accessori seems like of i let the
ages of the mini  jobs mee pnas benefit if
you need a and ben smartphone means the
same size that works not take a more of
you this play area nou het display most
people size and service adapted to his
de nationale vision nice bl  inds couple
as well as white walkers baby who
recently measurement phones white jester jazz
bass
minoan she stood this is the iphone lux
type like vcd so historical nature and
then smartphone whose knowledge lily
the pixels ten tyde wild shadow
derailleurs
thousand action line up the grains
perfect love  phones nardin af and
sophie donelli the foundation charge zo
mixer vegan wireless charger i an
action of the model number phone but hey
thailand logic socialists maxi frame
does anyone in headlines
that max is absolutely peaks and just 12
what's on the iphone 12 mee
instead of 15 what's  on all the other
iphones and don't know why
i come chip physical think before moving
smartphone die cosmology monologue to
porto bianche met die iding really know
this site and charging with magsafe and the
tank at wireless charging is
youth the ghettos peak numbers for a
few minutes of the beginnings surcharge
anyway co2 wat shift in wat water this
for very quickly pepers of de mars lower
ra  tes and seafolly barry this corps english
people never buy iphones because a very
fast charging fs wireless charging and
this internship i know where or a pink
she de smartphone means more like more
for sophie neat everywhere just feel more
fun to use name is arno where is  our country
combat flight chips of dare slander and
rené gude
screen big phones and my level i feel
like you're getting along for money but
there is something naais and barry compaq
smartphone app store games your basically
editing the wide web and equipment is
an eyeshadow
best compaq smartphone of the early and
ever hear what actually has been swift
at iphones aow de beggar's dance live
it with or a mini and there is one we
stick with the land core is because by
thomas more display was actually a
little bit more difficult  for may not
canaline
and that is generally prefer the big
screen for typing and watch videos and
adding photos and all the dust that the
longer on my iphone
pfiew and were typemachin  es video this
can offer monica slightly socialize
recommendation i think other de val
total people by phone 12 the cause of
the battery battery life by f72 nina in
was so podcasts to sexy and i know
there will give you an impression of
apple a calm but for  servant fine angelo
editor is i contact flagship van option
dear bartender cha the iphone 12 no that
can for who has the mini review of
rockets shark tank your margin and cash
correct far series in exloo
this